when I said crazy what were you
um
I look crazy what
what say like no one had that
gone
um like I literally like contacted him
almost everything and then just non-stop
like calling calling calling calling
calling then like basically when he did
pick up I was scream at him I was like
what the [ __ ] do you think you're doing
like basically like you know I don't I
feel like like I would never act like
that normally I feel like yeah anytime I
act out of character I would like say
I'm acting crazy yeah but that is your
character then you think so yeah because
if it's if it's not in you it can't come
out of you
I guess I mean
like do you not
so do you not think that if like
something were to happen to you like you
can
act some sort of way but um like you
wouldn't normally act yeah unless you're
in that you know specific situation like
you're just your emotions are like to
the max your stress levels to the max
like you know that it just pushes you to
a certain level I would say so I guess
you could still say like I acted how I
would if I was in that situation
like yeah yeah like what you said like
maybe didn't know it was you like you
had it in you until you found out about
yourself that day yeah
wow that's right
you think we get to you get to act
there's more of a um a leniency with you
acting crazy than men acting crazy
because if a man acts crazy it's like
what the [ __ ] like
I have dated an emotional man like yeah
but do you think that's do you think
that's because women are seen to be
these like emotional creatures yeah yeah
but but that's some it's one of those
double standards isn't it because like I
know women that have like smashed
people's cars you know like done all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] and it's like women
going crazy if a man was to smash a
woman's car like people be like oh my
God this guy's [ __ ] toxic you know I
mean like he's getting like
looked at in this in a different way
than women would yeah I agree with that
actually I think girls are given more of
a pass thing yeah it's freaking crazy
stuff but yeah I feel like that's like
the there's like a pro and con of being
men or a woman and so like you know
obviously being women I guess we got to
be a little more emotional whereas men
they get to be like more what is it
no I
I won't say that um women aren't
emotional but I think men
are emotional it just shows a little
differently and I think the reason why
women may have a little bit more
leniency towards their emotion is
because
if a man is say if a man smashed
somebody's car the next thought that
they're gonna think like what are they
going to do to me right it's just like a
fearful tactic because we've seen we
haven't seen any women
um the first thing that comes to my mind
says football player in the states he
literally picked up this woman I don't
know if it was wife girlfriend or
whatever and like drag like threw her
across the room like she was a rag doll
so it's just like things like that I
think comes like to mind when a man acts
their emotion is at that level towards
like crazy the thing is I've seen a man
do that to a woman but I've seen a man
do that to a woman after she has spot in
his face
slapped him in his face
and been like what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do you can't do [ __ ] and I'm like
just that physical action of him doing
that well in the general Public's eyes
make him seem like the bad guy and
people will kind of negate what she done
yeah do you know I mean like I'm saying
women get to act crazy and if a man
responds to it and say oh look at him
it's like did you not see all the [ __ ]
what actually happened I don't I don't
like when women do that because I'm like
I don't like men hitting women but it's
like you've put yourself in that
position like if if a woman if you did
that to a woman she would react
retaliate the same way but you did that
to a man so when a man react retaliates
that same way you wouldn't be like you
shouldn't hit women well don't don't
give him that lead way to retaliate in
that way because you don't know what's
inside a person to put them in that
position right
right I agree no one should be hitting
anyone at all no one should be hitting
like whoever hits me I'm hitting them
back I'm wrong and if you hit a man no a
man can hit you back you know it's just
that simple do you guys agree with that
if you if you punch a guy like he can
punch you back yeah I mean I feel like
that's just like completely unfair if
like women are just like
and then one of these other Men supposed
to just stand there like yeah take it
how are they supposed to process their
emotions like just sit there and be like
and that's why that's why a lot of men
don't actually report domestic abuse
towards them because they know it's not
going to be taken seriously it's like ah
it's a woman hit you what are you gonna
say it's like no but you know there are
a lot of women out here
out there actually physically abusing
men and men are taking it because they
kind of know that it's not going to be
taken seriously that does bring it up
like you know like the Johnny Depp case
yeah what happened I don't know that kid
so when suppose that actress's name
I forget her name but I remember the
recordings it was like
yeah she um I think she was just
a mentally and physically towards him
I think she filed the case against him
being abusive towards her but then I
forget what exactly happened but then
obviously like he won the case well when
she was abusing him like you could hear
the recording she was like no one's
going to believe you anyway no one's
going to believe you they'll just you
know people are gonna think did he win
he did okay and like I think there were
like some videos coming up like where
she would just like randomly raise her
hand and he'd like Flinch and it's oh
man it's just so sad
that's generally believed though yeah do
you know what I mean it's generally
believed that it's going to be him it's
going to be the man that's going to be
the reason there was a moment where he
kind of got black balled in like the
acting Community or whatever because
people actually believed that others yes
exactly well that's the thing I I feel
like when a girl accuses a guy of
something like people just automatically
assume like like what is it believe
believe all women believe all women but
I'm like some of these girls are crazy
like you can't you can't believe all
girls I've been I've been accused of hit
of hitting a woman really yeah I've been
accused what happened I've been accused
of pushing a woman down Two Flats of
stairs I had to go to court for it oh my
God I got found no guilty okay but it's
just the fact that I was there you were
there there was no injury he's like what
are you talking about like we we may
have had an argument yeah right but like
what are you talking about but because
women generally know they can call the
police and be believed they have to
investigate and I'm like but so what was
her evidence there wasn't any it was it
was my it was literally my word against
against hurts and so yeah yeah
I got found not guilty because they
heard they on delivered they only
deliberated for like 10 minutes and they
were like
so like disrespectful to like all women
that have been exactly it's just like uh
it's just so disappointing
like for women to even have the courage
to stand up because it's very like
frowned upon on different like aspects
and it's so hard yeah it is hard it's so
hard as an individual to stand up and be
like this is what happened to me and
actually stand up again to prosecute
another person for what they did to you
and they don't get found guilty because
of women that do lie and exaggerate
their situation for their own benefit
um and they you know what I mean and it
just it looks bad on other women that
actually do get a girlfriend I think
it's the reason why I can be accused
like me like okay I'm six foot two I'm
black yeah you know what I mean it's
easy to believe that I am always going
to be the aggressor you know I mean so
was it can I ask um what race you're
double black girl black there's a black
woman young black woman yeah as a black
woman and so but but she's a woman and
so she's going to be believable women
right she's going to be believed right
and it's like well if I have like no
history of abusing women like this just
comes out of the blue for me I know I'm
like what are you talking about but it
doesn't matter that really doesn't
matter well they can't undo the
character assassination like there might
be people that like believe like there
was a case where a dude was um he was
a girl said that she she was assaulted
by him and it came out that she lied but
like you can't undo everyone on campus
thinking he was a rapist for like oh
great gotta say great but like for um
great because you can't say great
um for two years you know because
they're however long the trial is
um yeah that does yeah
has there ever been a case where the guy
sues like the woman for defam like
defamation I don't know but I know there
was a case in America where yeah a woman
said that
um a guy raped her
she um but it came to find out that she
dreamed it was okay he actually dreamed
it but he actually went to prison for it
really you went to prison for grape yeah
but how did they find out she jumped
like because I think afterwards like
afterwards he appealed and have you
heard of it yeah like she she dreamed it
did she actually believe it happened to
her though I don't know I I don't
believe it I bet she just knew they must
have looked into a psychologist she must
have gone to psychiatric unit she would
have got evaluated if that was the case
that would have been the procedure do
you think that she was like too far like
she started singing and then she
realized there was a dream and she was
like too far in it and she couldn't she
like was too embarrassed to take I don't
I don't know but I think she should go
to jail I think any girl that like does
that should go to jail even if you
retract because you're like oh I'm sorry
like it was my mistake but remember
though when those kind of cases happen
we know the man
um don't know the woman like everything
is put out about the man he's in the
Press he's in the papers he's on social
media he was accused of this thing and
it's like who's the woman no one knows
but but I think nowadays nowadays they
do know the who the woman is because
they do tell like both stories but her
her character is not assassinated like
his is like a man if a managed use of
anything like that he's finished it
doesn't even matter where he did it or
not yes he's finished but would you when
can you argue the other way where they
do like say like oh this woman like she
does go out drinking she likes to wear
all this and this she's like barely
wears any clothes wear high but doesn't
mean you should be like well obviously
but I mean don't you wouldn't you say
like they're like what is it the media
is basically trying to blame the woman
yeah and that's and that's the thing
that's why when I hear me personally
when I hear that men have been accused
of something like this
I just wait for all the evidence to come
out I'm not saying he did it didn't do
it I'm not there she's lying that she's
not lying I'm just like let me just wait
to see but people generally there was a
case um in the UK last year there was a
woman
um I actually spoke about it there was a
old lady who killed her husband right
she was like Penelope Jackson was her
name Penelope Jackson she killed her
husband and when the police came and
because they had their body cameras and
they um they filmed it she was so not
she was like yeah he deserved it he was
an abuser and he done this and blah blah
blah and because she said that yeah all
the women just jumped to her defense
yeah she must have been going through so
much she must she must have been pushed
to the edge come to find out when it got
to a jury she got 18 years for killing
him because she was lying but the thing
is is that it doesn't really matter it's
the fact that she said it and women just
believed her yeah and that's that do you
know what I mean that that's that yeah
you're you're now guilty into you're
proven innocent when you when something
like that happens
or even with that like Supreme Court
Justice of the US
um what was it
um you know what I'm talking about the
Supreme Court Justice a couple years
back where that girl like came out
um and said he assaulted her in college
right as he became like he was nominated
for the court yes
and the media the media like painted him
as such a bad guy but if you watch the
full like interrogation and like the
trial and stuff they found nothing on
him and the whole world like they see
him as a Grapist well the president of
the United States currently has a
allegation that gets him from a woman
called Tara Reid and we haven't even
heard about it Tara Reid um Joe Biden
has been accused by a woman named Tara
Reid of digitally inserting his fingers
in her while he was in office
that's the case no one cares about it